[Music]
all right
um
thanks Mark for taking time to talk to
to Forbes happy to
um what is the biggest technological
innovation of your lifetime I think if I
had to pick to date it would probably be
you know mobile having every being
giving everyone the ability to connect
but um but I think going forwards I mean
the two that I'm the most excited about
are AI is is obviously just uh having a
huge moment right now there have been
awesome breakthroughs in the last year
on this and I just think that this is
going to transform all of the different
products that that we have and
everything across the industry
um so you know my own view is that there
isn't going to be one kind of big
Central super intelligence I think that
they're going to be a lot of different
AIS that people interact with for
different things and that we interact
with throughout our day
um and I'm really excited to to try to
help make that happen the other one that
I think is going to be very exciting
over time
um is the is the metaverse right the
ability for people to to basically feel
physically present with another person
um no matter where you actually are in
the world right so in the near term we
get that with VR where you can you can
jump in and you can be embodied as an
avatar and just feel like you're right
there with another person there's
something that's sort of magical about
that that you don't get in any other
kind of screen or technology that we use
that you know nothing really replaces
the feeling of being there with another
person
um but of the long term I think we're
going to get that through a pair of
normal looking glasses where you know we
could be having this conversation in the
future and one of us could just be a
hologram sitting here and having a
normal
um kind of full interaction feeling like
we're physically there with each other
and I think that that's going to be
really really just a huge deal but and
that's you know it meta the main thing
that I'm focused on is
we um you know we talk about building
the future of human connection and I
think you know those two areas really
blend together to be that right for you
know giving people the ability to feel
present with another person no matter
where they are and then also over the
long term giving people the ability to
interact not just with people but also
AIS and you know businesses that they
care about in different ways is just all
part of the future of making the world
more connected so I think it's super
exciting I mean this idea of having
putting on glasses and then I you could
be a hologram or is that
a decade or more away like any idea no I
hope not unless really yeah less well
first of all you are going to be able to
do it and you can do it with Quest Pro
today and when Quest 3 comes out you'll
be able to do it with mixed reality
right it's the first headsets that we
made were virtual reality which
basically meant that
um you kind of were fully immersed in a
world around you now you put on the
headset and by default you're kind of in
your living room or you see the physical
world around you and you see digital
objects overlaid on that and I think
that that's
um so we're starting to get that and I
think over the coming years
you know we'll we'll get to the Zone
where it's um
you know the the digital world isn't
just something that we access through
phones or screens it'll be
um more and more just kind of blended
into the world around us you know a lot
of the the art or the games or Media or
screens or you know it's actually an
interesting thought experiment just to
think about how much of the stuff around
you could be a hologram right when your
your chair can't be because you need to
physically sit on it food can't be
because you need to physically eat it
but like most of the other things around
us actually probably could be
um could be Holograms over time and um
that's going to open up a lot of a lot
of interesting opportunities too so
you're getting that with with these kind
of headsets like Quest already that
millions of people have access to and
then my hope is that over the next
several years we'll also get
increasingly powerful glasses but that's
a very hard tech problem because you're
basically fitting like the equivalent of
a super computer into a pair of normal
looking glasses so
um making things small
is uh is is hard that's I think that's
why I was thinking you would take a
decade because like thinking about the
difference in size between what the
quest three and the Ray-Ban stories is
that are pretty different you know yeah
and it's not necessarily that you're
going to be able to do the same thing
with both just like you know a computer
might have more power on your desk than
your phone but you know you can still do
a lot of awesome stuff with your phone
um you know my guess is that glasses
will walk around throughout the day with
them
um they won't be quite as powerful as
what you'll be able to do with a full
headset but um so maybe if you're like
sitting down to work on something
or if you're like a surgeon and you're
gonna do a remote surgery then you
probably want like a more powerful VR
headset not just a small pair of glasses
but for like Mobile use cases walking
around
um in places where you're going to be
interacting with a lot of other people
live where you you want to be you you
want to see the people around you not
just have a headset on
um I think that's going to be super
useful so yeah no I think it's gonna be
this decade what would you say is the
hardest part of running meta
um
well I think the hardest
this may just be for me because the way
that I'm oriented but um
you know it's a big company and
I think getting the people right and the
culture right is the thing that both
matters the most and is sort of the
hardest to dial
um you know especially as a company
scales and
um
one of the things that I've found over
time is you know we've gone through
these different
periods as a company where sometimes
people think we're awesome sometimes
people think we're terrible
um you know sometimes people think we're
just like everything we do is going to
be a winner and sometimes people think
like we're like the gang that can't
shoot straight and like you know we we
you know just nothing that we do is
gonna work but regardless of what people
are saying externally
I've found that if you can keep
sort of a a good amount of internal
cohesion
you can get anything done right whereas
even when you know sometimes people are
very excited about the company if people
internally aren't actually aligned to
what we need to go do then it's very
hard to get things done so
um
for me I mean it's it's maybe somewhat
of a
of a trite thing to say but I think like
I mean this is all about
getting people right like and getting
the right people to to involved and
building great teams of awesome people
to
um to be able to build
new things that are super impressive for
a lot of people so that's that that to
me is is probably what I spend the most
time focused on and um and I it's
probably the most important part of
running a company that sounds I think
that sounds fair to me
um who is your biggest rival and how are
you competing against them
um
well
we have a lot of competitors
um in pretty much everything we do from
social media to devices to advertising
to like all all the different areas but
I don't know I I guess one philosophy
that I've always had
is I actually think your biggest
the thing that determines your destiny
is not a competitor it's how you execute
um and I think most
most companies probably
Focus too much on competitors and maybe
even focus too much on ideas and I think
at the end of the day a lot of what
makes great companies Great is the
ability to just like relentlessly
execute and efficiently execute and do
that rigorously and just get better and
better at it all the time and that's one
of the things that we've really focused
on so I don't know maybe it's like um
it's sort of like a very
I don't know like martial arts view of
the world or something that you
um you know it's like when you go into a
competition it's not you're not fighting
another person you're fighting yourself
right and you're you're just trying to
be a better version of yourself and make
the company better and able to better
execute
um every day but I I I always tell our
company that whenever I've gotten asked
that question like you know a lot of
times over over time and it's always
just no like we don't control our
competitors but we do control what we do
and yeah we can get better at it and
that's how we we build better things and
you're and you're okay obviously
mimicking features that other
competitors and trying to roll them out
here right I mean you want to learn from
what what people in the world are
enjoying and finding useful right and
and yeah I think you want to be humble
about it right it's you know not every
great idea is going to come from us you
know I like to think that you know we
invent a lot of things but
um but no it's I I think that the idea
that like we would create everything
that people want to use is ridiculous
right so yeah of course we want to be
looking around and seeing what people
find useful and trying to
do our own take on those things and make
them even better and I think that that
that kind of
natural competition is is how these
ideas get honed and things get better in
the world
if you're in a match with Elon and he
uses the heel hook move how do you
defend against
um well I don't think that fight's gonna
happen but um but
but look I mean I I love the stuff
um you know I like competing I like
doing it with friends it's like an
important part of my daily my daily uh
workout but um and I like competing too
I started um doing Jiu Jitsu
competitions earlier this year I want to
do an MMA competition
um or do do kind of a formal fight
sometime in the next year so I'm looking
forward to that
um I'm probably gonna do it with someone
who takes the sport really seriously and
does it competitively or is a
professional
um so I'm training hard and looking
forward to it but no to your question
about a heel hook that's a relatively
high level Jiu Jitsu move so I I think
the person would have to be pretty
serious and experienced in order to be
even attempting that